[Music]
I'm Megan
I get accused of being the master of
killer doll movies
it's nice to meet you cutie do you want
to hang out I designed Megan to protect
Katie from feeling lonely you're gonna
pair with her it's insane right she's
designed to be the ideal companion Megan
your goal is to protect Katie from harm
is the input request received 100
as her AI evolves she becomes very
protective of Katie I won't let anything
harm you and it's pretty terrifying
Megan
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
be reminded of the fact that this
technology is here we're not that far
from something like Megan existing and
that is pretty unsealing
listen to me Brandon
it's really creepy but playful at the
same time you know just before she's
about to kind of cut someone in half
recalibrating response model
[Music]
s
but let's do a horror film it's
terrifying you're gonna walk out of the
theater and feel like that one creepiest
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
ever again
you don't provoke us all we will